أعتقد أن هناك فكرة مفادها أنك
تذهب إلى المكتب أو مكتبك ويتوقع منك
أن تكون منتبهًا ومنتجًا للغاية
لمدة 8 ساعات متواصلة أو أكثر،
لكن البروفيسور مارك يقول إن هذه ليست الطريقة التي
نعمل بها نحن البشر حقًا. عقود من
البحث في  تظهر المختبرات أنه
عندما يحول الناس انتباههم
بسرعة، وهو ما يعني في الأساس القيام
بمهام متعددة، فإن ذلك يرتبط بزيادة
التوتر، والنتيجة الأخرى هي أننا
نعلم أن الأشخاص يرتكبون المزيد من الأخطاء،
والنتيجة الأخيرة هي أن الناس يستغرقون وقتًا
أطول لفعل شيء ما، وفكرة تعدد
المهام التي تؤدي إلى
كفاءة سعيدة هي  ليس صحيحًا أنك لست
أكثر كفاءة ولا أنت أكثر سعادة،
أنت أكثر توترًا، يبدو الأمر كذلك ولكن
هنا تكمن المشكلة، حيث يعد تعدد المهام
جزءًا كبيرًا من الكيفية التي نتوقع بها جميعًا أن
نعمل ونعيش هذه الأيام، فقد أصبح
ضرورة لذلك  ما يجب فعله ما الذي يمكن أن
يفعله الأشخاص لمساعدتهم على إنشاء عقل أكثر انتباهاً،
فالكثير من الأشياء التي نقوم بها على
أجهزتنا تكون تلقائية، فنحن نرى صورة
هاتفنا ونلتقطها دون
تفكير، ونرى إشعارًا عبر البريد الإلكتروني،
ونتحول على الفور إلى إرسال الفكرة عبر البريد الإلكتروني  هو أن
ندرك هذه
الأفعال اللاواعية لرفعها إلى
الوعي الواعي، يمكننا تشكيل خطة على سبيل المثال،
حسنًا، سأعمل المزيد من الدقائق على
هذا، لذا سأعمل حتى
نهاية هذا الفصل وبعد ذلك
سأأخذ قسطًا من الراحة، وهناك أسلوب آخر هو
التدرب على التفكير المدروس، الأمر الأكثر
منطقية بالنسبة لي هو تخيل نفسي المستقبلي
في نهاية اليوم، فأين أريد
أن أكون في الساعة 7 مساءً؟  أريد أن أشعر بالاسترخاء
كلما كان التصور الملموس الذي
يمكن أن نحصل عليه حول أنفسنا في المستقبل كلما
تمكنا من التحكم بشكل أفضل في
انتباهنا حاليًا. والشيء الآخر هو
أننا بحاجة إلى إعادة صياغة طريقة تفكيرنا
في جدولة يومنا بشكل استباقي
وتصميم  المهام التي يتعين عليك
القيام بها بناءً على
إيقاعك الشخصي عندما تكون في أفضل حالاتك وفي
ذروة تركيزك ووفر تلك الأوقات
للقيام بتلك المهام التي تتطلب
العمل الجاد والطاقة الأكثر إبداعًا